Where my ladies at?
Seriously, we’ve spent a lot of time learning about
the origins of sociology, and all of the founders we’ve
talked about so far have been men.
That’s because, when sociology was
becoming an academic discipline, women didn’t
have the same access to education.
In fact, it was considered improper in the
19th century for women to write articles and
give talks to the public.
And this continued for decades, with some
of the top universities not allowing female
students until the 1970s.
Which sucks.
But it also raises an important question:
Why do women and men get treated differently?
This is a question that sociologists can answer!
Or, well, we can at least try to answer it.
Gender-conflict theory applies the principles
of conflict theory to the relations among genders.
Specifically, it looks at how social structures
perpetuate gendered inequalities.
Now, the functionalist approach has historically
held that gender inequalities are a natural result of each
gender taking on the tasks they’re best suited for.
But many modern sociologists don’t share
this view.
Economic and political power structures that
reinforce traditional gender roles often cause
more dysfunction than function.
Restricting access to education by gender
is a great example of this dysfunction:
Denying women access to quality education makes our
society worse by squashing the half the world’s potential!
Sociology’s understanding of society wouldn’t be complete without the women and feminists who started the conversation about gender as an academic field of study.
First stop: sociology’s forgotten founder,
Harriet Martineau.
[Theme Music]
Harriet Martineau was the first female sociologist,
born in 1802 in England.
Unlike Marx or Durkheim or Weber, who are hailed as the forefathers of sociology and get entire chapters devoted to their theories, Martineau typically gets, at most, a couple of sentences in a textbook.
Martineau started out kind of like the Crash
Course of her time – bringing research to
the masses in easily digestible bites.
She wrote a best-selling series called Illustrations
on the Political Economy, which used fables
and a literary style of writing to bring the
economic principles of Adam Smith to the
general public.
She was a favorite of many of the leading
intellectuals of the time.
Even Queen Victoria, who loved Martineau’s
writing so much that she invited Martineau
to her coronation.
But this was just the start.
Martineau decamped for the United States and
spent two years travelling the country, observing
social practices.
She went from North to South, from small towns to Washington DC, sitting in on sessions of Congress, a Supreme Court session, and a meeting with President Madison.
She then captured her observations in two
books, Society in America and How to Observe
Morals and Manners.
The first was a set of three volumes that
identified principles that Americans professed to
hold dear, like democracy, justice, and freedom.
Then she documented the social patterns that she
observed in America, and contrasted the values that
Americans thought they held,
with the values that were actually enshrined in
their economic and political systems.
Martineau’s observations included some of the
first academic observations of American gender roles,
and she dedicated much of the third volume
to the study of marriage, female occupations,
and the health of women.
Despite the title of her second book – How
to Observe Morals and Manners – it was not
a guide to etiquette.
It was a treatise on research methodology,
describing how to do cross-cultural studies
of morals and moral behavior.
Martineau talked about interviewing, sampling,
bias in observation, the problem of generalizing
from individuals to a whole society –
many of the hallmarks of modern research.
She wrote about class, religion, suicide,
nationalism, domestic life, gender, crime, health –
and this was all before Marx, before
Durkheim, before Weber.
And her English translations of Comte’s
work on positivist sociology were so good
that Comte himself told her:
“I feel sure that your name will be linked with mine.”
But of course, Comte was wrong.
Soon after her death, Martineau’s work was
forgotten.
It wasn’t until the 1970s, when feminist scholars
began to revisit her work, that the full extent of her
influence on sociology began to be realized.
That’s right, feminist scholars.
Now, I know for many people feminism is a
loaded term.
And I want to make sure we’re clear about
the historical and sociological context for
feminism as I’m using it here.
Here, we’re defining feminism as the support
for social equality among genders.
This is in opposition to patriarchy, a form of social
organization in which institutional structures,
like access to political power, property rights,
and occupations, are dominated by men.
So feminism isn’t just associated with activism;
it’s also a scholarly term.
Feminist theory is one school of thought in
the study of gender.
And over time, feminism has gone through many
different forms, often categorized as waves.
Let’s go to the Thought Bubble to look at
what’s known as feminism’s first wave.
In the 19th and early 20th century, the first wave
of feminism focused on women’s suffrage – or,
the right to vote – and other legal inequalities.
That’s because, in the 19th century, all
property and money that a woman had legally
belonged to her husband.
Imagine that.
Not being able to earn a salary that was your
own, not being able to own land, not being
able to write a will.
And on top of that, you can’t vote, which
makes it a little hard to change these things.
It was these issues that prompted the start
of the Women’s Rights Movement, which began
with a meeting of 300 like-minded women – and
a few men – in Seneca Falls, New York in 1848.
Early feminists Elizabeth Cady Stanton and Lucretia Mott organized the meeting to put forth a manifesto on women’s rights, which became known as the Declaration of Sentiments.
This convention was the spark that set off the
women’s suffrage movement in the United States.
It took many years of activism – court cases,
speeches, protests, and hunger strikes – until
women finally won the right to vote in 1920.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
The first wave of feminism didn’t only affect
legal issues.
It was also where many of the ideas about
societal roles of gender first got their start.
Take Charlotte Perkins Gilman, for example.
You might recognize her as the author of the
short story “The Yellow Wallpaper.”
But she was also a sociologist and social
activist.
Early in the 20th century, she published papers
and books on society’s assumptions about gender,
focusing on marriage, childbearing, and the
assumed roles of women as housekeepers and
men as breadwinners.
She wrote: “There is no female mind.
The brain is not an organ of sex.
Might as well speak of a female liver.”
Notice how she worded that – the brain is
not an organ of sex.
Sex refers to biological distinctions between
females, males, and intersex individuals.
But gender refers to the personality traits
and social roles that society attaches to
different sexes.
Think about it this way: Do men and women act
the same way across all cultures and time periods?
If gender arose only from biological differences between men and women, we would expect to see all cultures defining femininity and masculinity in the same ways.
But we don’t.
From the work of anthropologist Margaret Mead in the 1930s, to the research done today by economists Uri Gneezy and John List, scientists have found that gender roles change among societies, and over time.
And this idea – the idea that gender has
societal origins – has formed the backbone
of the second wave of feminism.
Books like The Second Sex by Simone de Beauvoir
and The Feminine Mystique by Betty Friedan
argued against the idea that women were a
lesser sex, who should be resigned to taking
care of children and the home.
The second wave of feminism focused on female
participation in the labor force, equal pay,
reproductive rights, sexual violence, educational
equality, and divorce.
This was the era of Title IX, the legalization
of contraception and abortion, no fault divorce
laws, and the Equal Pay Act.
But it was also an era of divisiveness within
the feminist movement, with many feeling that
women in positions of power focused on issues
most relevant to white, upper middle class women.
These divisions led to what’s known as the
third wave of feminism, starting in the 1990s,
which has focused on broadening the definition
of feminism to encompass issues of race, class,
sexuality, and other forms of disadvantage.
The ideas evoked by the third wave are nicely
represented by author and feminist bell hooks:
In her book “Ain’t I a Woman,” hooks
writes:
“The process begins with the individual
woman’s acceptance that American women,
without exception, are socialized to be racist,
classist and sexist, in varying degrees ....”
That’s a heavy statement.
Most people don’t think of themselves as
racist or sexist.
But one of the underlying ideas behind third
wave feminism is the acknowledgement of the
structures of power that create inequality
across gender, race, class, and other dimensions
of disadvantage.
There’s a term that’s used a lot in modern
day feminism, which maybe you’ve heard used
recently: intersectionality.
So what is intersectionality?
You add a little race-conflict theory in with
gender-conflict theory, and a smidge of Marx’s
theories about class conflict – and you
get intersectionality, the analysis of how
race, class, and gender interact to create
systems of disadvantage that are interdependent.
The term intersectionality was coined by race
and gender theorist Kimberlé Williams Crenshaw.
She wrote that the experience of being a black
woman couldn’t be understood just by understanding
the experience of a black person, or the experience
of a woman independently.
Instead, you have to look at how these identities
intersect.
How you – yes, you, in particular, you – see
society and see yourself is gonna be wrapped
up in the identities you have.
I, as a cisgender white woman, will have a
different experience in the world as a result
of my own interlocking identities.
And when it comes to our understanding of
gender in this societal mix, we have to thank
Harriet Martineau, whose work was one starting
point from which the waves of feminism unfolded.
Today we learned about Harriet Martineau
and gender-conflict theory.
We also explored the three waves of feminism,
as well as intersectionality.
Next time, we’ll look at another important
figure in sociology Max Weber.
Crash Course Sociology is filmed in the Dr. Cheryl
C. Kinney Crash Course Studio in Missoula, MT,
and it's made with the help of all these nice people.
Our animation team is Thought Cafe, and
Crash Course is made with Adobe Creative Cloud,
If you'd like to keep Crash Course free for
everyone, forever, you can support the series
at Patreon, a crowdfunding platform that allows
you to support the content you love.
Speaking of Patreon, we'd like to thank all
of our patrons in general, and we'd like to
specifically thank our Headmaster of Learning
David Cichowski.
Thank you for your support.